I believe that poverty is the defining
issue of our time
I believe that poverty is threatening
our very democracy and I mean that
sincerely it's threatening our very
democracy the existence of it the future
of it I believe that poverty is a matter
of national security
because these numbers are not
sustainable one percent of the people
cannot continue to own and control 40%
of the wealth the top 400 richest
Americans 400 individuals have wealth
equivalent to the bottom 150 million
fellow citizens that's not a democracy
you can call it an Oleg Archy you can
call it a plutocracy but it's not a
democracy and that's why I say that
poverty is threatening our very
democracy so there is clearly the issue
of poverty there's the issue of income
inequality but I think there's a third
issue that we don't talk about enough
it's through some economic mobility so
income inequality is the difference the
gap between the rich and the poor well
let's be frank to some degree you're
always gonna have a gap between the rich
and the poor economic mobility is about
how you lift the poor up from the
suffering that they have to endure every
day so the conversation is really not so
much about income inequality or wealth
inequality as it is about economic
mobility that's the issue we have to
focus on
you